let's talk about romance this is where
in my opinion it gets a little bit scary
there are many people who are
sub-optimal mates the bottom tier of
society as you define it by status have
a harder time getting mates well what if
you studied a million Tinder
conversations to get the first date well
there'll be tools probably called first
date AI that can AI from first convo all
the way to the date getting set take it
a step further pen pals people who wrote
letters to each other back and forth
back and forth back and forth for years
and they fell in love well what if you
remove the person altogether it's just a
company that provides you with romance
so let's take it a step further we have
the phone version of this and you can
hear a voice that has been tuned to your
preferences that talks to you and
listens to you and all of a sudden you
fall in love with a robot